اقتصادي كبير تشكله الاضرابات على العمال
المضربين في فرنسا كل يوم اضراب يحسب
اجازه غير مدفوعه الاجر وبعض الاضرابات قد
تمتد لاسابيع مثل ما هو الحال في قطاع
الطاقه او النظافه النقابات العماليه وجدت
الحله من خلال صندوق للتبرعات تلقى ارقاما
خياليه خلال اقل من ثلاثه اشهر
التبرعات يتم جمع اغلبها خلال التظاهرات
كليمو وجمال موظفان مضربان عن العمل تطوعا
في فريق يجمع التبرعات من متظاهرين دخلهم
محدود اصلا لكن لحظه وضع قطعه نقديه في
الصندوق هي الفوز الكبير
في شركتنا يوجد مئه عام مدربين عن العمل
سنحصل على ما بين 30 الى 60 الف يورو ليتم
توزيعها على كل العمال المضربين حتى الان
تجاوزت التبرعات ثلاثه ملايين يورو رقم
سيساعد النقابات على دعم الموظفين
المضربين من اجل ضمان اكبر تاثير ممكن
لهذه الحركه ضد خطه الحكومه رفع سن
التقاعد
نتلقى تبرعات كبيره جدا هذه هي المره
الثالثه التي نقوم فيها بجمع التبرعات
خلال التظاهرات مررنا على محطات القطارات
والناس يتضامنون معنا ويبتسمون لنا هي
معركه عصبها الزمن فالحكومه تراهن على
عامل الوقت املا في ان يرهق الموظفين
المضربين لكن النقابات ومن خلفها
الفرنسيون يبدو انهم على استعدادا للتضحيه
بالقليل من اجل كسب معركه للمستقبل
فديده العربيه باريس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات